hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i want to show you the perfect brr
buy refurbished refinance rent property
which is also
a hmo it's going to be a little small
hmo we're here in liverpool it's a nice
part of liverpool
and this house was purchased by the way
this is not my house
i found it negotiated with the help of
alistair cunningham
and we negotiated buyers for 43 000
pounds
now this is for an investor who's very
very happy i'm kind of jealous of the
house
it's a little small deal but i thought
i'd give you a documentary and show you
exactly what's happening
so this is the house 43 000 pounds it
does need a whole
lot of work so come around and i'll tell
you what needs to be done
today is friday on monday we're going to
rip this whole thing out
we're going to take the carpets out
we're going to knock it back to brick
we're gonna take everything off we're
gonna get a new central heating system
put in
and we're just gonna gut the place now
the crazy thing is
is that builders tend to be pretty slow
with refurbs
this house completed on two weeks ago
we've got the builders coming on monday
the electrics have been tested the
structural surveys have all come back
everything's all good it was bought from
auction at 43 000 pounds
once it's done up i honestly think it's
gonna be worth i'm hoping
it's gonna be worth about a hundred
thousand pounds it might even be worth
more than that i've got a friend that's
got a house in the same street
and his was valued at 110. he used the
same builders we're using on this
project so it was bought for 43
hopefully the value will come in about
100. even if it comes down
at 90 000 it doesn't matter because the
refurb
is only going to cost about 30 000
pounds so either way
we're pulling the money back out and my
investor who owns the property
when he pulls the money back out what's
he going to do he's going to sink my
praises
and he's going to reinvest the money
probably into another project that i'll
find as well
why would someone find their own deals
when i can find deals for them this is
the lounge
this is gonna remain a lounge uh good
open spacious lounge that room
downstairs is gonna be a nice bedroom
we're gonna put an ensuite into the
bedroom and rent it out and we're hoping
to achieve around about 400 pounds
per month kitchen needs coming out
dawn is coming off i might even take
this door off right now ah
there we go jeez you can see this house
is a wreck it's just falling down
but by the way this is what's happening
monday monday's pet teardown day monday
we're going to tear the kitchen out
monday we're going to tear out the the
toilet how does the toilet get like this
how does this happen i don't know we're
tearing out the shower we're tearing
everything out
on monday getting this place ready
ready to restore it to its former glory
in liverpool
okay former glory is probably a bit of a
bit overkill so this house
um by the way i tell you something this
property was
was secured on auction last year
no not last year this year i don't know
but it was about almost a year ago very
very long time i think it might be the
beginning of this year
it just shows you that properties can
take a long time you've got to be
patient my investor was saying what's
happening samuel what's going on
it's taking forever but the deal was so
good
we couldn't pull out of it we had to
keep going and now
and this is another crazy thing my
investor was saying to me
samuel what's going on what's going on
what's going on we bought it on auction
terms
so the price can't change over the last
12 months
prices have gone up in liverpool this
completed two weeks ago forty three
thousand pounds
if we put this back on the market i
reckon we could sell this at sixty
thousand pounds
as it is as it is this pro
this room is going to be another big i
don't think i don't think you can see
how big this room is this is a big room
uh another ensuite in here in this room
and this is going to rent out
for about 400 pounds david down the road
he's got a property that's written out
he's the exact same same builders
he rented out 400 pound 400 pound 500
pound three rooms
so jesus if we can get that i'll be very
very happy
another double room right here we're
gonna put an ensuite in this
room now we could
we could technically get four rooms in
this whole house
because there's another room there a
small room but our plan
is rather than cramming rooms in what
i'm thinking to do is to get big ensuite
rooms what we could do
is we could just i'll show you we could
rent out
we could rent out this is a room this
could be this could be a bedroom it's 70
square foot
but i'm thinking let's make this into a
big
beautiful ensuite like a bathroom
and then a door here and then the door
takes you through to this
nice big room
nice big room so so you got room ensuite
big
room ensuite big downstairs room ensuite
big nice
value fingers crossed coming around
about 100 000 pounds if it's down valued
nothing we can do about that but we'll
try our best rent it out
uh approximately four hopefully closer
to 500 pounds per room
well again we we can't predict the
market it's a crazy time right now but
because we bought the property so cheap
because we bought it at 43 grand
we can only make money on this we can
only make money on this i mean houses in
liverpool right now
in this area even the ones that are run
down they're selling for like 70 grand
70 grand that'll run down like this so
when you buy that's the thing with the
buy refurbished refinance rent strategy
you need to buy the right price
you need to refurbish at the right price
that's what i'm going to be overseeing
this to make sure the builders
are you know are doing their job i've
also got a really good team the builders
will do their job they're good builders
uh shout out to the builders i'll get
them in on the next video and then you
want to refinance at the right price as
well
might be that we try and refinance this
on a commercial valuation but i'll let
you know that on a future video
so overall i'm feeling happy if you want
to learn more about property investment
if you want to learn to find properties
like this
you want to negotiate them whether you
want to buy them yourself package
themselves into investors like we've
chose to do on this property
you should join me at the property
investors crash course i'll leave a link
in the description
it's free to attend two days with me and
you can do the same
thanks for watching if you want to see
my entire start to finish buy
refurbished refinance
property that i did in darlington you
can check that video out right here you
can see the whole process start to
finish
if you want to see a playlist of people
that i've helped become financially free
i help people become financially free
every week check them out right here
see you next time subscribe thanks for
watching